Oh my god!
You guys can't hear it!
Wait!
Everything's messed up.
Hold on.
You guys can't hear it.
No.
Wait a second.
One second.
Which one is it?
Oh no!
I'm gonna guess.
Oh, I found it.
I have to restart?
Restart now.
No!
Hold on.
Redo.
Oh, it's loud.
Oh, it's loud in my ear.
Wait, I don't know the words.
Oh, it hasn't started yet.
How is the audio?
Why is all my stuff frozen?
Something strange?
Sleeping in your bed.
Who are you gonna call?
Ah!
Uh, nobody.
Uh, who are you gonna call?
I don't know the words!
The, the, the words!
Hold on!
Uh, I'm afraid of no ghost.
Oh, I got him.
I got him.
I'm afraid of no ghost.
Ever seeing things.
Running through your head.
Who can you call?
Ghostbusters!
An invisible man?
Sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
I'm afraid of no ghost.
Oh, I keep hitting my ceiling fan.
Who are you gonna call?
If you're all alone.
Pick up the phone.
And call!
Ghostbusters!
Da, da, da!
Freaky Ghost Maid!
Ouch!
Freaky Ghost Man!
Freaky Man Baby!
Who are you gonna call?
Ghostbusters!
Maybe have a dose?
Freaky Ghost...
Ghostbusters!
Who is that?
Uh,
my chat is frozen in now.
Oh gosh, let me tell you something.
Ghostbuster makes me feel good!
I'm afraid of no ghost.
No, no.
Ghostbusters!
When it comes to your door.
Unless you want some more.
I think you better cough, cause I just feel good.
Ghostbusters.
Who you gonna call?
I think you better call.
Ghostbusters.
I'm gonna fix the chat in like two seconds.
I can't see you guys.
Who you gonna call?
Ghostbusters.
Louder.
Who you gonna call?
Ghostbusters.
Uh, he likes the girls too.
What the hell are these lyrics?
Who you gonna call?
Ghostbusters.
Finally, it's over.
Hold on, I'm fixing chat now.
Oh, you guys are so tiny.
There we go.
A never-ending song, for real.
Okay, hold on.
I think you guys like that.
And, uh, keep visible.
Perfect.
Hello!
I'm gonna close out of this for a second.
Hi.
Hey.
Hello.
Hi, Minto.
Hi!
Oh, I still have a reverb on.
Hold on.
I don't have it anymore.
Hi, boss.
Hi!
Hold on.
Cool.
Yay!
Hello!
Your third dimension is showing.
Don't look.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, thank you!
Wait.
Can I see donos?
I don't know if you... Can you guys hear them?
I don't know.
Is this me or is...
Using the inside of Mint's sleeve, consider... flashing.
What?
A big yaoi hand?
Ma'am, don't grab me like that.
And here it goes.
Thanks for the five gifted!
It's five.
Sorry.
Sorry, I can't...
The twenty gifted!
I'm sorry.
Thank you for the twenty gifted.
I owe you a one.
Owe!
Ha ha.
Woo!
Yikes.
What?
Did I change it to low latency?
Let me double check.
Not that I could fix it now.
I can't fix it now, you guys.
Anyway, welcome... Oh, I didn't.
Okay, it's fine.
Sorry, some of the messages seem a little delayed, but it might just be you.
You.
This might be your fault.
Oh, she can't count.
She broke her neck on stream.
Yeah, I can really do that.
Hold on.
You wanna see me break my neck?
Uh oh.
Hold on.
I think I gotta adjust something.
There we go.
So talented!
For some reason my feet are always in the floor.
Unless I try to touch my toes.
And then I just go sink back into the floor.
It's just a ghost thing.
I don't know where floors are.
Or what they are.
Here, let's go around my haunted abandoned abode.
Let's uh...
Let's go together.
I haven't actually explored this place.
So here, I'll go like here.
And you guys follow.
Wait a second.
Why is there a second window here?
Go away?
Okay.
Does anyone really know?
No.
Here we go.
This is where I was hiding.
Oh, there's another room over there.
Okay, freaky.
Let's go this way.
This is where I was hiding.
Right here.
Nice and comfy.
Yeah.
Looks like something will pop out at any second now.
Is this your house?
No!
This is my grandma's house.
There's some bad words on the ceiling.
Do not read.
Do not interact.
I like that guy though.
That one right there.
That one's pretty fun.
Your grandma lives like this?
Yep.
And we got some more stuff over here.
Wow.
Let's go over here.
I actually have some fun.
This one looks like the dog from...
Wait.
Can you see it?
This one.
It looks like the dog from Adventure Time, does it not?
Jake.
Sasuga, the legendary grandma.
Yeah.
Jake.
We have another room.
Whoa.
Jam.
That's what we were doing.
We were...
Clearly, we should have been in this room and say...
Oh.
Behind you.
Wait.
You guys guess...
Hold on.
Let me grab this.
Take a guess what is...
Take a guess what is behind you right now.
Take a guess.
Not behind me.
Don't look...
Don't look at that.
Behind you.
You.
You right now.
Me?
No.
I'm right here.
That'd be stupid.
Guess.
I'm not seeing any...
Correct answers.
That's fine.
In fact, I probably wouldn't have even been able to tell who it was if it wasn't for the hat.
Now, let me...
Back up.
Let me show you.
Oh my god.
It's a Polari the...
Polari.
Not Polari.
It's a...
Polari the Blatter Boys.
Oh my god.
I didn't recognize you without your hat on, Polari the Blatter...
I give up.
Okay, let's keep going.
Let's keep going.
I did it twice.
Any other special cameos we can find?
I'm going to try walking into this wall.
Wait.
There's more yonder.
Okay.
How do we get over there?
Here.
Hold on.
I'm going to try and back you up.
Can you see?
No.
Okay.
Over yonder.
How do I...
Hold on.
Back it up, Minto.
I don't think we're going to be able to go over there.
How do we get there?
Thank you.
Two.
What's it say?
Is this what the maid cafe looks like behind the camera?
You know, actually, it's pretty funny.
What you see on my stream is actually just like a big old cardboard cutout.
What the?
There we go.
Let's go this way.
If we can't get over there, I guess that's it for us.
Yonder.
I want...
I wish to explore yonder.
This has to be the door.
I see right there.
You guys...
You guys can't see.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can grab you.
All right.
I'm going to try and grab you.
Oh, sorry.
You just see my hand.
There you go.
All right.
See?
Yonder.
We must go beyond.
How do we get over there?
To yonder.
Look over there.
That's the entrance.
That's where I came in actually because I remember the little text on the wall.
But we can't go through.
We can't go through.
Sad.
Oh well.
We tried.
There was an attempt.
I have a bunch of other worlds.
Oh.
I would like to take you guys to... pretty much all of them.
I haven't explored before.
I wanted to explore them with you guys.
And at each one, we'll do like a karaoke or something.
And we'll have some... some fun.
So this is what it's like when we forget to take our meds.
Forget your meds.
Don't take them.
Don't take your meds.
Forget them.
Don't do that.
Actually, don't do that.
Take your meds, okay?
Let's see.
I found a bunch and I put them all in my favorite... in my favorite place.
Like my favorites for VR chat.
Such as... Titanic Survival Experience.
Let's go to that one!
All you
see is black.
Oh, this is a hefty boy.
Okay.
We have to survive the Titanic, everybody.
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
And obviously, we know what song we need to sing here.
Clearly.
Don't let go...
Where are you guys?
Guys?
Oh!
There you are.
Welcome to the Titanic.
Every night in my...
Can't grab you.
There we go.
Sorry.
I'm throwing you around.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Every night in my dreams...
What is this?
Oh, is this a game?
Wait a second.
This is not just a regular place.
This is like a game game.
There is currently a round playing right now.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
I'm the only person here.
What do you mean by that?
There's a... up there it says...
There is currently a round playing right now.
If you wish to experience this from the beginning to end, please wait until this text says...
The Titanic is not sinking.
No way.
Guys, we have to wait until the text says the Titanic is not sinking.
Approximately 30 minutes!
Who else is here?
But it's just me.
The room is haunted.
Are you interested in role play events?
We're role playing the Titanic!
No.
Things to remember, keep in mind.
Stay seated in the lifeboat.
Photos of the Titanic below the ocean.
Wait, wait, this is kind of cool.
Look, look, look.
Woah.
Wow.
Near... far...
It's split in two?
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
How do you know?
How do you know it's split in two?
We can spectate.
Actually, let's go spectate and see what we can see.
If someone is doing this.
Alright guys, hold on.
I'm gonna put you right...
Sorry.
I have to get used to VRChat once again.
We're gonna go spectate.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Do you see it down there?
Do you?
Oh my god!
How am I supposed to spectate?
They're so far away.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's not even... There's some boats down there.
You can barely see them though.
It's really dark.
It was night vision.
I can't get any closer I think.
This spectator mode is like outer space.
This is what the aliens saw when the Titanic was going down apparently.
Is it even sinking?
I don't know.
I think it's slowly turning sideways.
Maybe.
We're in creative mode right now.
We have just a black screen?
No, you don't.
Really?
Is it that dark?
Oh, it's like really dark.
Yeah, yeah.
It's really, really dark.
Yeah, it's slowly tilting.
It's slowly tilting.
Oh my gosh, this is kind of horrible.
This is what they saw during the Titanic for real.
It was actually like this pitch black, you know?
It was actually like this dark.
This is crazy.
Yeah, you can see the lights of the ship.
Oh my gosh, get out of there!
Get out of there!
Swim!
Actually, don't swim.
Oh my gosh, I'm going to pretend to be that one guy from the Titanic movie.
Who gets out because he says, I have a child.
That's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to steal a baby and then claim to have a child.
Relive the horror.
Oh my gosh, it's really starting to sink though.
It's really on its side.
Good thing we didn't do this.
You know what?
It's probably better that we stayed here and let all those guys do that, you know?
It's probably better that we're here and not over there.
Just saying.
All I see is Minto hair.
You can barely see the boat.
Oh my gosh, it's really starting to get sideways.
I see it actually moving, moving now.
Wow.
Can we get any closer?
I'm trying to, but I don't seem to be able to.
I thought like spectate meant like go onto the ship and as like a ghost mode, you know?
Oh.
Oh wait, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I feel like, can I even sing this here?
Titanic, Jack and Rose, Metal Gear.
The lights turned off, the lights turned off.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, it's going down.
I don't know if you'll be able to see it, but...
There's like little boats down there, you see them?
They're really hard to see.
There's little boats down there.
They're escaping.
Escaping.
Oh my gosh, it's so sideways.
Titanic!
Oh my god.
I don't know what the boats are doing though.
I don't know.
Or the rescue boats, if there's anybody on them.
Who was, who was here?
The brightness is through the roof.
Okay.
How do I, how do I get back to the main room?
I'm gonna, okay.
If you guys have a, like if you guys turned your brightness up, prepare your eyes.
We're about to go back into the lit room, okay?
We're about to go back into the lit room.
Three, two, one.
Woo!
You guys are there!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, you guys come back to me.
Okay, there we go.
They are at, let's see.
Second class staircase is flooded.
We can go on the stern maybe.
We can maybe go on the stern.
Let's see.
Oh!
Oh my god, we're on the ship!
Oh, guys.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Guys, I didn't make it!
You guys, I can't move.
You guys, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
You guys!
I can't respond.
Oh, I'm sinking more into the water.
Oh my god, I'm sinking into the water.
Guys!
Can you see me?
Wait, can you see me?
I can't see anything.
It's too dark.
Oh my god, guys, come back to me, come back to me.
Come back to me.
I can't see anything.
I'm falling!
Guys, help me!
You're way up there.
I'm so, I'm down in the...
Please, guys.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Hold on.
Could you see me?
Can you see me?
Can you?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, guys.
Can you see me?
I can't see you, guys.
I can't see anything.
You guys.
You guys, I think we didn't make it.
We're stuck in the darkness.
I can sometimes see...
Oh!
We're going up.
Somehow.
Hold on.
I'm gonna show you guys.
Look.
There's the ship!
Oh, wait.
No.
Never mind.
Can it work, please?
The ship?
Oh, I think we missed it.
The ship is down there.
And we're currently dying in the water.
I think we didn't make it.
So, I think we're gonna respawn.
It won't let me.
You guys were trapped in... Oh!
Oh, my God.
The Titanic has fully sank.
Well, that was something, wasn't it?
Hold on.
I gotta readjust in my room for a second.
I got a little overwhelmed.
You're okay?
Okay, there we go.
We're okay!
We're okay.
Let's... You know what?
After experiencing that, I don't feel so good singing My Heart Will Go On.
There were two other sister ships.
The Olympic and the Britannic.
Only one of them survived!
Let's restart.
No way.
You guys, I don't think we'll live.
Let's go to another world.
Let's go to this one.
This one will make us feel so good.
Okay, guys?
Okay.
Here we go!
That was really fast.
Now, this could either be super great or super terrible.
So, we'll see.
We'll see.
Excuse you.
Oh.
Hello?
Whoa.
You guys are probably like, what's going on?
Hello.
Welcome to another world.
It seems like this one is a game, as you can see.
Touch and play.
But what are we playing?
That's a great question.
I love cubes.
Are we playing Snake?
No, no, no.
We're playing...
Worms.
Welcome to Slither.io!
Wait.
I can't let go of the camera.
Let go of the camera.
Welcome to...
Why is this so hard?
Slither.io!
Welcome!
Welcome to Slither.io!
We're playing Worms!
We're playing Worm City!
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
Hold on.
I gotta figure out how to make this so I don't touch it.
Sorry.
It's my chat window.
I keep moving it on accident and I don't want to.
Lock.
How do I lock you?
Maybe.
Let me try this.
Edit mode.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
We're good.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you!
She became a worm for us.
She loves us.
All right.
Let's do...
Wait.
I'm gonna turn around.
And press jump to go faster.
We're gonna play.
Okay, guys?
All right.
Aim your mouse.
Oh.
Right hand.
The snakes will follow it.
Push the button that you use.
Whoever has the longest snake is the most superior player.
All?
Touch to play.
Oh, God!
Oh, my God!
I'm...
I'm using my hand to control him.
You guys...
This is so awesome!
I'm gonna be the biggest worm.
Oh, my gosh.
This is kind of awesome.
This is kind of great.
This is kind of fantastic.
Oh, it says jump to go faster.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, but I lose all my things.
Okay.
All right.
Don't jump to go faster.
Snake looks so...
He's doing his best.
Yay.
Guys, this is the optimal... most optimized way to watch Slither.io.
I'm just gonna say...
I'm just gonna say I think we did it.
I think we've done the greatest thing of VTuber... I think we've peaked.
We've peaked.
I'm just saying.
I could... I think I'll... I will be back here.
What should we sing while we play Slither.io?
What should we sing?
What's some songs?
Snake Eater?
No, no, no.
I have that for later.
My heart will go on.
Okay.
I have to like twist my hand.
Wait, can I pause this?
Pause the game.
How do I win the game?
How do I stop the game?
Oh.
There.
There we go.
Are we okay?
I don't even know where you guys are.
There we go.
Are you?
Alright, let's do free fall.
It's shut up.
Are you okay?
Yeah.
I'm fine, actually.
Let's see.
What song shall we sing?
Heart will go on.
And then we'll play.
Give me a second.
Let me set it up.
My heart will go on.
Don't mind my body, please.
Don't mind my body when I do that.
Can you hear it?
Every night in my dreams.
I see you.
I feel you.
That is how I know you.
Go on.
Far across the distance.
And spaces between us.
You have come to show you.
Go on.
Near.
Here.
Far.
Wherever you are.
I believe that the heart does go on.
Once more.
You open the door.
And you're here.
In my heart.
And my heart will go on.
And on.
There was room on that boat for two of them.
On the little door.
I know that's been said before, but...
Love can touch us one time.
And last for...
Ah!
Never let go till we're gone.
Love was when I loved you.
One true time.
I hold you.
And my life will always go on.
Near.
Far.
Wherever you are.
I believe that the heart does go on.
Once more.
You open the door.
And you're here.
In my heart.
And my heart will go on and on.
And...
Where are you?
In the dark?
Don't I sound like Celine Dion?
It's my Celine Dion impression.
Are you impressed?
Please be impressed.
Please clap.
Okay here we go.
Here we go.
Well, the big...
You're here...
There's nothing I fear...
And I know...
No!
Please!
We'll stay...
Forever this way...
You are safe in my heart and...
My heart will...
Go on and on...
This one.
My chat froze again!
I'm just gonna die.
No!
Let me... let me fix you guys!
Let me...
Let me fix you guys!
I don't know why you keep breaking.
Usually it doesn't happen like this.
Let me try... is there a refresh?
No?
Let me just open you eyes up again.
Sorry.
I have a little way to read chat while I'm streaming in VR, so...
That one...
It went pretty well!
Lampy, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you everybody... thank you!
Let's go to another world, eh?
Shall we?
We are in the freezing ocean...
Oh, let me turn off the...
Uhm...
The...
Blblblbl... Reverb...
There we go.
Okay.
I have another world that I would like to go to.
Thank you for the rose.
That was a good performance.
Thank you.
Miss Mel-chan, thanks for the five gifted!
Actual five.
I can read it.
Let's see.
Worlds.
Okay.
This one!
I'm so excited for this one.
Hold on.
I can't see it because you guys are in the way.
One second.
Let me redo.
I'll do it this way.
Okay.
This one!
Get ready.
Actually, I haven't been to any of these.
So...
Wait a second.
So I honestly don't know...
Karafun, get out of here please.
I don't know how many of them are.
But that's part of the fun, right?
This is Outer Heaven, isn't it?
No.
Close, but no.
Okay.
Let's go.
Hopefully it's not too loud.
Oh, this one's hefty.
Hefty.
Screams made it more realistic.
Hopefully they're not too like...
Too like... for your ears.
You know?
Why is it keep...
Why do you guys keep freezing on me?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
What is this?
What do you guys see?
What is this place?
Oh, hold on.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, hey there.
Oops, sorry.
Welcome back, soldier.
It's time to fly.
It's time to dog fight.
It's time to...
Fly!
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
Big reveal.
Yeah!
This plane.
We're going to the danger zone, baby.
Highway to the danger zone.
Yeah.
Shoulder cam time?
Absolutely.
Alright.
Hold on.
Let me get in position.
We're actually going to fly it.
It says... how to fly.
You can fly without an airplane.
In most flight worlds.
But this is useful for...
Eight pages.
Okay.
Jump...
Finally the jet hag.
Shut up!
Jump whilst in the air.
Pull the left or right trigger.
Left trigger moves you out.
Right trigger moves you in the direction that you...
That's all I need to know, right?
Wait a second!
You guys, they have the Top Gun Maverick OST!
No!
No way!
Goodness gracious!
Great balls of fire!
No way!
Oh my gosh!
No, no, no!
Wait, you guys, look!
They also have like a bunch of Gundam OSTs and stuff.
What?
Oh my God!
Where is the... Oh, there's Ace Combat OST!
Oh my God.
No way!
Oh my God!
Is it playing?
I don't hear it.
Oh, wait!
I think I turned off...
World...
Oh my God, you guys.
Okay, let's go!
Which plane should we take?
DMCA time!
No, no, no, no!
It's like we're playing the game!
Don't worry about it.
Is it really loud?
Hold on, let me check.
Let me double check that it's not so loud that it's like...
Okay, it's good enough, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's good, it's good, it's good.
Take the F-16.
How do I get in?
Oh!
Oh my God!
Oh my God, you guys!
We're taking off!
This is it.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, wait.
Hold on, let me fix this real quick.
Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, oh my God!
How do I go?
I'm gonna go!
I think?
How do I start?
I'm in the wrong seat?
Oh, you're so right.
Wait, how do I get into the front seat?
Oh!
Oh my God, it's really loud.
What?
Grabbing the trigger!
I can't hear anything!
You guys, we're moving!
I'm home!
Uh...
We stopped moving.
Something happened.
Hold on.
I'm doing it!
Uh...
Um...
Something's going on.
Uh...
Close the canopy?
Oh, I have to do that.
How do I do anything, though?
Uh...
It's so loud!
Is it behind me or no?
Oh my God.
Should've read the instructions.
No, no, we're okay.
Equip?
Equip what?
What am I equipping?
We're okay.
Keep that up.
I've launched enough Top Guns to know what's going on!
I don't think my hands can reach the...
The controls!
I gotta put on my seatbelt, maybe!
No?
Um, that's the eject.
Don't want that.
We'll turn it down some.
I can't reach this.
Don't pull the yellow lever!
I'm not trying to!
This is what I'm not trying to!
I'm just trying to touch anything!
You guys, I wanna fly!
Let's go read the instructions.
Let's go read the instructions, right?
I know why I can't fly the plane!
I know why I can't fly the plane.
It's because...
I wasn't...
It's because I wasn't in gear!
It's because I wasn't...
I wasn't looking the part.
Look at this.
Look how cool I am!
Oh my god!
Okay, hold on.
Follow me.
We're gonna have to go turn off the music.
Wait a second, you guys!
I'm on the leaderboard!
That's me!
Oh, Instance Master.
Me?
A master?
No!
I'm a maid!
I serve the master!
No!
That's silly talk!
Silly talk!
Okay, let's read the rules.
Okay.
Entering a vehicle, stand next to a seat and point below the...
That's what we did?
Throttle control.
Whilst in the pilot seat of the vehicle, you can control the throttle by...
Grip...
Grip button on the left controller.
Any time you are holding the grip down, you are holding the throttle.
Okay...
What else is there?
Oh!
Wow, this is really detailed.
Deaths won?
No...
It doesn't even say that...
Oh.
I did... How did I die?
What?
This is incorrect!
Don't look at this part!
That's not accurate.
I completely...
I literally didn't even take off.
How did I die?
It knows.
You're a ghost.
Yeah, but in the game, I'm not a ghost.
Okay?
Uh...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah...
Flight limits.
Never even took off.
Somehow died.
I must drive on to the cab...
Wow, there's like a thing up there.
I see like a...
A hot air balloon or something.
I see other planes.
They can do it.
I can do it.
If you die IRL, you die in the game.
Oh no!
Um...
Flight...
Limits.
Okay.
Then the cruise.
Catapult.
Wait, what was...
This is all this stuff, right?
Nope.
Oh yeah.
The HUD.
Oh...
We'll get it.
Keyboard!
See?
This is supposed to be played on.
Keyboard!
Not my fault.
Mucho texto.
Refueling!
Look at the way I run.
Wow!
Wait, there's other planes.
Let's check them out.
Skippa, skippa.
Yeah, pretty much.
Whoa...
This place is kind of beefy.
It like really lags.
It's okay though.
Looks good.
Got that hunchback.
Wow!
YouTuber?
Question mark?
Let's...
Guys, we're taking...
Diamond dog!
Diamond dog?
At the top?
I think we're taking this plane.
Not...
It's like... Diamond dog...
Like...
Bootleg diamond dog.
Wow, anime.
Let's take the Itasha plane!
Hold on.
Before we go though...
Let's get some pictures in front of it, you guys.
Okay?
You can take some pictures of me in front of my plane.
Oh wait, you need the anime in it.
Hold on.
Where did you guys go?
There you go.
Cheese.
You didn't hear my butt crack, did you?
Ow!
Let me move away from my desk.
Seeing in VR is dangerous.
Did you guys hear the bonk?
I'm okay.
It was just my wrist.
Okay.
It was my wrist.
What's another...
Gimme a pose.
Gimme a T pose.
Worm?
Is this good?
Jacko pose.
Isn't that like...
Like this?
I don't know if I'm doing it right.
This is like a dog.
It's like this, right?
I'm Jacko pose.
Like that, right?
Okay, I think we're good.
I think we're ready.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to leave you behind.
Alright, guys.
Okay, here we go.
Go here?
Why do we go and then we stop?
Na na na na na...
Na na na na na.....
Na na....
Na na na na...
Na na na....
Na na
na...
Na na na na na.....
Na na na na na....
Where -
Why won't you stop the stamping?
Na...
Na na na....
Thumbstick?
Thumbstick doesn't do anything.
Oh, I'm shooting!
Canopy!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I did it.
I did the canopy.
Cruise!
Oh, sorry.
It's so quiet now.
Feels good.
Are we okay down there?
I think we're cleared for takeoff.
Hey mom!
Highway to the... hold the trigger.
And move.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, not gun.
BOMBS!
Oh, I can do a bomb.
But I'm not gonna do that.
Hold on.
Um...
Canopy?
Oh, nope.
Oh my god!
Guys, I think I'm gonna throw up.
Guys, I think I'm gonna throw up!
I'm gonna throw up!
We're okay.
I think this is a sitting activity.
This is a sitting activity, I think.
Wait, why am I... why are we sideways?
Why are we sideways?
Why are you guys sideways?
Okay...
We took off!
You guys, we did it!
We flew!
Guys...
Gosh, I have nerves.
We almost died but we didn't.
But we didn't...
Alright, let's sing a song!
Let's go sing it in front of our plan...
Let's go sing it in front of our plane.
This way.
Oh my gosh, it's back!
It's still there!
Do you see it?
We survived!
Should we try again?
Oh, sorry, you're over here.
I'm informing you, the family of the pilot was at lost at sea.
The last words I'm going to throw up.
It was actually really...
Raiders?
Welcome, Raiders.
Thank you!
Hold on, let me get to my plane.
There we go.
Oh, you can't probably recognize me.
I'm Mint!
I'm in my gear because I'm a professional.
Top Gun.
Guys?
Maverick who?
Oh my god, Top Gun.
That's me, baby.
Top Gun.
Who raided me?
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Sorry.
Looking like Goose.
Oh my god.
Talk to me, Goose.
I'm going to sing some karaoke.
I have two songs that I want to sing here.
Since this is VR chat and karaoke time.
So...
I'm just going to sing some karaoke in front of our plane.
Oh, sorry if I'm a little all tied up here.
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I think I got it.
No spelling errors.
Oh, wait.
I think I spelled it wrong.
I think I got it now.
Oh, no, I spelled it wrong again.
Sorry, it's really hard to type.
No, I spelled it... W.
No W.
Okay, here we go.
I'm good.
Dunna Dun dun dun
Revving up your engine Listen to her howling What?
Roar?
Sorry I can't read.
Metal under tension Begging you to touch and go Ahh!
I've read it but it's small!
Highway to the...
Danger zone I can't read the lyrics right now Turn to the...
Danger zone
Yeah, there we go.
Heading into twilight, spreading out her wings tonight.
She got you jumping off the deck, shoving into overdrive.
Highway to the danger zone.
I'll take you right into the danger zone.
You'll never say hello to you.
Wait, get it on.
Run, run, overload.
Wait, what's this part again?
Oh no, it's freezing.
I can't read it.
Then you can go.
I'm gonna go!
Yeah!
The hotter the edge, the hotter the intensity.
Highway to the danger zone.
I'm gonna take you right into the danger zone.
Head into the danger zone.
Highway
to the danger zone.
I'm gonna take you right into the danger zone.
Highway to the danger zone.
Head into the danger zone.
Ride into danger zone.
Highway to the danger zone.
Ride into the danger zone.
I think it's like overheating my computer.
Woo!
That was good.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can make you guys stop freezing on me.
Thank you for the claps!
You guys...
You're a Top Gun.
You guys are the toppest gun.
You guys are... Top Gun here?
You guys... Wait.
You guys, okay?
Don't ever forget that.
Don't ever forget how...
You guys are top... a top.
You guys are a Top Gun.
Okay?
I'm trying to brush my hair out of my ears.
Deserves all the claps.
Thank you.
Alright.
Maybe for the next song I should change back.
I don't know.
I feel... I'm feeling this though.
I'm feeling this.
Let's just stick with English song.
I was going to sing...
I was going to sing Love Deterrence but...
Maybe next time.
Since my computer is like overheating.
Looks good on me.
I like the fit.
This model is great.
It's awesome actually.
Feels like...
But I'm like so... I'm so stoic and mysterious.
You can't see what I'm thinking.
You can't see...
How I want to peel it.
Actually...
Wait.
Does it have any emotes?
Hold on.
Let me see.
Whoa!
I can change the color.
And then also what's this?
I can change...
What helmet I want.
Wait.
What do you guys like?
This one?
Hi.
Peace...
Or do you like this one?
Peace, peace, peace, peace.
Which one do you like?
Turquoise color.
It only has like...
these colors.
It won't let me do in between.
The circular one, the first one.
This one?
Peace, peace.
Peace, peace, peace.
Oh, hold on.
Quick actions.
Does nothing.
Peace, peace.
Peace.
Come on.
Come on, peace.
Peace.
Yay!
Oh, there we go.
Cool.
Oh.
Trying to just do a thumbs up.
There.
Cool.
Oh my gosh, I look so cool.
I kinda wanna go again.
Let's try it one more time.
Okay, guys?
I won't throw up.
I promise.
Maybe.
Who knows?
I don't know.
I might throw up.
Okie dokie!
Let's do...
Let's do... Canopy!
And it goes down.
Nice and quiet.
Wait, you guys are like so far away.
Hold on.
Nice.
Hold on, I'll move you a little bit like this.
How about like...
Like that.
They can still see me.
Oh, sorry.
Hi, mom.
And we're gonna go...
Oh, wait.
What was it again?
Oh, cat...
Here we go!
Pull up!
Oh, gosh!
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep!
What's the beep, beep, beeps mean?
Wait, can you guys see anything?
Oh, god.
We're gonna crash again.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm close.
I'm close.
There you are!
This is so like Outer Wilds.
That's a great idea!
Let's go to Outer Wilds!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Let's go to Outer Wilds!
Let's go!
Yeah, yeah, baby.
Let's go.
It's initializing.
Connecting.
Highway to the danger zone.
If you experience motion sickness, I advise you leave immediately.
You will be subjected to unnatural gravity.
And other spatial effects that may induce nausea and or headaches in unexperienced VR players.
Proceed with caution.
I'll be fine.
Let's just try it.
Whoa!
Enter the sun station?
We're going into the sun station.
Wait, you can explore five areas.
Timber Hearth, Timber Hearth's Moon, Ash Twin, Ember Twin, Dark Bramble.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're going to enter the sun station!
Oh.
Whoa!
Why can't I grab you anymore?
Whoa, there's an observation pool and everything!
Wow!
This is kind of freaky.
Why can't I?
Oh, I think it's on lock.
That's why.
Yeah, that's why.
Okay.
It's kind of loud.
Let me turn it down just a little.
Hello?
There we go.
Okay.
Welcome, everybody, to Outer Wilds Sun Station.
I'm your host, Minto Phantom.
Pilot version.
Pilot Minto.
Where are you guys at, actually?
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
Let's see what other places we have.
We can go to...
Let's see.
Snap turning.
Oh, I can turn that on if it...
Oh, wait.
Let me get a little... There we go.
We can do snap turning.
Actually, I'm okay actually right now with the non-snap.
Oh, never mind.
I need it on.
Just kidding.
If Mint loses chat again, it's because we're quantum.
Let me turn on snap turning.
Okay.
Oh, that's much better.
You guys okay over there?
Okay.
Let's go into the observation pool.
Nothing to observe.
Everything is fine.
Pequod!
Yeah.
Pequod.
What is world inspector?
World inspector.
It says...
L...
Use.
Can't use it.
Oh, use this.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Whoa.
Oh, use again.
Use.
There we go.
Whoa.
Oh, I think this is where we choose where to go.
Let's go to Timber Hearth, you guys.
Let's go to Timber Hearth.
Boom, boom, boom.
Can I go?
Oh!
Oh, uh...
Can you guys see?
Where are you?
Where are you guys?
Stop being quantum.
Oh, I see you, I see you, I see you.
I see you, I see you.
Dum, dum.
I have to get you guys back up right.
What's wrong with you?
Is it the gravity?
Why is it defaulting to this?
It's defaulting to sideways.
That's weird.
Okay, I'm gonna stop you guys from being sideways.
Uh,
if I could let go of you.
Alright.
So sorry for the disturbance.
Dum, dum.
I'm gonna cry.
Oh, I'm gonna cry.
Oh, there's the sun and everything.
This is super low poly.
Timber Hearth, look at this.
It looks great though, don't get me wrong.
Actually, the galaxies...
Oh, my bad.
The galaxies look so great too.
I guess you kinda can't see the stars, can you?
In my view, I can see them.
I can see every star.
All of them.
I can see this one, and that one, and this one, and that one, and this one, and that one.
I can see almost every star in the universe.
Let's see.
Alright, let's keep going.
Oh, we're in the water.
Dum, dum, dum, dum.
Dum, dum, dum, dum, dum.
Low poly.
Eek!
What's this?
Is this the...
Where are we?
Wait, is this the...
The observation?
Wait, is this supposed to be the...
No, this is... Yeah, wait.
You guys, I think we're at the...
Museum?
It looks a little different than I remember.
But the music...
is so nice.
Do you think we'll die?
Do you think if we're here for long enough we'll die?
Are we in the floor?
How did you get so low?
There you go.
And you're kind of crooked.
I can't help you guys anymore.
I can't help you guys any longer.
You guys need to help yourselves, okay?
I feel tilted.
I'm feeling woozy.
If I auto-level, it does that, so...
I have to manually do it.
I'm so sorry.
It's kind of really relaxing here, though.
I can see!
I can see the moon from here!
Can you see it?
There!
That's our moon!
You see it?
How do we get there?
I'm lost.
Wait, you guys, I accidentally exited the building!
And I can't get back in!
Wait, you guys!
I think I...
I clipped through the walls and I can't get back inside!
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
I'm coming.
I'm coming for you!
She's speedrunning.
Good thing I'm wearing this helmet, or else I wouldn't be able to breathe.
Look at that moon!
I mean, sorry...
Look at all those chickens!
Shut up!
I don't want to see you guys talking, okay?
I don't even want to...
I don't want to see you guys talking.
I'm gonna lift you up some.
Is there anything else down there?
Can I walk on this?
Guys, if I die...
If I die...
You'll come with me, right?
You'll come after me, right?
Take my hand!
Wisp!
It's your time to jump!
Let's go!
I made it!
Oh no, I'm stuck outside here.
Wait, you guys.
There's a wall.
You can't see it, but there's a wall.
Oh, you guys, I can't get inside.
Hold on, I'll show you.
I can't...
I can't get inside.
You guys, I'm trapped.
You guys, I'm...
Let me in!
Please!
Please, let me in!
Oh, guys!
Guys, I'm slipping!
Guys, guys, I don't mean to alarm you.
I'm on a cliff right now, you guys.
Please, you guys.
I don't mean to alarm you, but I'm in a really bad predicament right now.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna jump to this one over here.
There's another one?
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna do...
Behavior, look at me.
Look at me!
Struggling!
Okay, see this other platform right here?
I'm gonna jump to it.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
It's not that far.
And there's, like, less gravity here, right?
Alright, here we go.
I'm gonna make it!
Guys...
I have nowhere else to go.
Guys, nowhere else to go.
But down.
Ouch!
Let's go to another world, shall we?
How long have I been streaming for?
Oh my gosh!
Already so long.
I can't stream for so long so long today because of...
you know.
Let's go to this world instead.
Actually, this one.
I haven't been to this one, but by the name of it, it should be something that I enjoy, so...
IKIMASU!
Oh, I'm hitting things in my room.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna...
I'm hitting things in my room.
Gotta move around a little bit.
Chuuu!
Thank you!
Chuuu, thank you.
What does it say?
What are you doing?
Can Frogbert please sing Louis Armstrong, what a wonderful world.
Whoa!
What?
That's weird!
What is going on in this world?
Okay, hold on.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to...
Fujiyama!
Oh, sorry.
The behavior is always look at me.
That's right.
Fujiyama!
The cat's crying voice is...
Meow!
If the dog walks...
Where?
Can we go to Fuji?
I can't read these.
Can we go to Mount Fuji?
Mount Fuji?
Or is it just a dragon?
Flying around.
Hold on.
Oh!
I have to get these right!
You guys, if I get these...
If I get these questions correct, then we... then an entrance will appear.
Nooooooo!
I have to get these right.
If I get it wrong, I have to go back.
I have to restart the world.
No way.
Okay.
Anybody who's better... who's more good at Japanese than me?
I'm just a pilot.
I'm just a...
I'm just a pilot, okay?
I can't read it.
The dog walks.
Is he tired?
Is he hungry?
Maybe he becomes tired?
I hate kanji, me too.
I can't read this first one, right?
This one down here.
I can't read this one.
What is this?
Three?
Wait, what is three?
Pick number three, my lord.
Is the first one trust me?
Wait, this is... Am I reading the kanji wrong?
I can't read kanji at all.
Mmm...
Even if a dog walks...
The dog...
Mmm...
Mmm... Okay, we're gonna...
We're gonna brute force it.
This one!
I'm going to where I feel comfortable.
I'm going to where I know I'm welcome.
Japanese not Jozu.
For real.
What are they?
Are they like some sort of...
Are they some sort of like...
Let's see...
We are Craft!
We are craft!
Welcome to the VR craft where you can do VR and play Minecraft!
It's VR and it's Minecraft and they're all together together and we can play VR and we can also play Minecraft!
Block by block one by one till you shout enough!
I'm done!
And then you will be blow it up and then you'll start another build.
It's Minecraft but in VR!
And we can build a lot!
Um, I actually don't know what this is all about so let's just go in, okay?
Oh!
I don't like you looking at my hunchback like that when I'm running around.
Hold on, I'm going to move over.
I'm going to move.
Can I walk next to you?
Can I walk?
Here.
I'll walk next to you.
Okay.
Here we go.
Wow!
We're in Minecraft!
Oh my god, wait, hold on.
This is the perfect moment!
Oh my god, watch, watch, watch.
I'm going to say my favorite Minecraft quote, you guys.
I am Steve!
Steve!
Let's keep going.
Whoa!
I'm building!
Oh my gosh!
You guys, how high can we go?
How high can we go?
You can actually build in this Minecraft!
You can build for real!
You can build in this Minecraft!
Wait, what about the void?
What's like all that over there so high?
What if we fall?
I am Steve.
What happens if we fall?
I'll test this, guys.
I won't make you go, okay?
This one...
This one's all me, okay?
This one's all me.
I'll take it.
I'll take the hit, okay?
Hold on, I'm going to move you guys back a little bit.
Don't think of...
Don't do anything stupid!
Don't think of coming after me, okay?
Alright?
Catch you on the flip side.
Oh!
There's an invisible wall.
Okay, let's keep going in this Minecraft.
You think when it gets dark the mobs will come out?
We don't have anything to fight.
Or fight with.
Nice dance.
And all we have are...
are just...
dirt blocks.
I can't even mine these trees.
But you know...
Can't even chop them.
Your girl fail energy today is very evident.
What do you...
What do you mean by that?
CQC them.
You guys, it's starting to get dark.
Alright.
This is kind of beautiful though.
Look at this.
Minecraft is beautiful.
Ouch!
Watching the sunset.
You and me.
The moon!
Turn around.
Turn around right now.
The moon is out.
Uh oh.
Guys.
We are in trouble.
He isn't right behind me.
Isn't he?
What do you mean by that?
Tsukikakirei.
Look at this place.
It's basically on fire now.
Actually, why is it on fire now?
What happened to the moon?
Hmm...
Kermit?
There a bit.
You think that I'm so similar to that other iconic frog?
No.
I get that all the time though.
And I'm actually...
I'm my own person.
My own frog if you will.
Why is the music so dramatic?
Oh you guys it's getting dark.
You guys the mobs are gonna come out.
The mobs are gonna come out.
The mobs.
What do we do?
I should be the only creeper here.
Kiss.
It's actually...
It's actually quite bright.
For it being...
Nighttime.
The moon is so bright.
I guess there wouldn't be any mobs spawning here.
Cause it's so chill.
Now watch me whip.
Now watch me nae nae.
Whip.
And nae nae.
Frogbear my beloved.
What I can do that?
How far can I go?
Ta da!
Yeah!
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Hold on.
Wait!
You guys!
I don't think I saved the pilot.
Oh okay.
I saved the pilot.
Oh thank goodness.
Woo!
I feel way more comfortable in this than anything else.
That's funny.
I'm born to be a pilot.
Anyway.
Let's sing something here.
What do you guys want me to sing?
In Minecraft.
Oh my gosh.
I can sing anything that you want in Minecraft.
Sing the danger zone.
No.
Nothing.
Sorry.
English songs.
Because it's the only thing that I have right now.
Enderman's coming to get you.
No he's not.
Uh uh.
Uh.
Hmm.
Snake eaters for later.
California girls?
Great idea!
That's an excellent idea.
Dang it.
Okay hold on.
I gotta type it.
Where's my computer?
There it is.
I think I spelled California wrong.
California girls.
Where is it?
Oh here it is.
Oh let me turn off Minecraft music.
Ah!
I know a place.
Where the grass is really greener.
Wet and wild.
There must be something in the water.
Slipping.
Gin and juice.
Oh it's better than the palm trees.
Ah!
Try to break their necks.
Try to keep a little sneak peek.
You could travel the world.
But nothing comes close to the golden coast.
Once you party with us.
You'll be falling in love.
Oh oh.
California girls.
We're unforgettable.
Daisy dukes bikinis on top.
Sun kissing so hot.
We'll melt your popsicle.
Ah!
California girls.
Oh!
Sorry the window keeps getting so small.
Now put your hands up.
Ah!
Sex on the beach.
We don't mind sand in our sleddos.
Leek in my jeep.
Snoop Doggy dog on the stereo.
Oh!
You could travel the world.
But nothing comes close to the golden coast.
Once you party with us.
You'll be falling in love.
Ah!
California girls.
Oh!
Can you keep the dukes bikinis on top?
Sun kissing so hot.
We're unforgettable.
We'll melt your popsicle.
Ah!
California girls.
We're unbelievable.
Fun, fresh, fierce.
We gotta unlock.
West coast represent.
Now put your hands up.
Ah!
Tone 10, fit and ready.
Turn it up cause it's getting heavy.
Wow, wow, west coast.
These are the girls I love the most.
I mean the ones.
I mean she's the one.
Kiss her, touch her, squeeze her buns.
Oh!
The girl's a freak.
She drives a jeep.
And lives on the beach.
I'm okay, I won't play.
I love the bay.
Just like I love L.A.
Venice Beach and Palm Springs.
Summertime is everything.
Oh, hanging out.
All that ass hanging out.
Bikinis, zucchinis, martinis.
No weenies.
Just the king and the queenie.
Katie, my lady, look here.
Oh, baby.
I'm up on you cause Representing California.
California girls.
California.
It got really small again at the very end.
It was okay.
I messed up my hits.
That was a good adventure, wasn't it?
Let's go to another world.
Where shall we go?
Oh wait, hold on.
Let me turn the music back.
Yay!
Thank you.
Did you like the dance?
I forgot that.
Okay, it was like...
This.
And then this.
This?
I'm running into stuff in my room?
Nice job with the Mutsuki dance.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have some other ones on here, but let me see how long we are.
With streaming?
Okay.
I think just one more world, you guys.
Let's go to a museum.
It belongs in a museum.
I have maybe this one.
Let's see how it is.
Actually, hold on.
Let me...
Do some stuff first.
Here we go.
California
girls.
California.
California boy?
California...
California girl?
Like let's do the one in Vegas?
It's a Grozny grad who wants to go there so they...
I'm taking you to the best part of MGS3.
Welcome to Snakes and Lion...
Oh!
That scared me.
Oh my god, that scared me.
So much.
Guys.
Oh my god.
It's explaining to you how to do it.
Oh my god, it scared me.
Welcome everybody to, yes, the ladder!
The infamous... well, maybe not infamous.
Reach the top before the song ends.
Timer will begin automatically.
Rewards stay if you reach the... wait, there's rewards?
What rewards are we talking about?
Reach behind your ears to grab the climbing orbs.
Place the orb to the ladder.
Hold the use button to grab the ladder and pull yourself up.
When dropped, the climbing orbs will return to the back of your head.
Are you guys ready?
Are you guys ready to climb the ladder?
Climb the ladder!
Climb!
So I grab it from my ears and then I place the orb on the...
Oh!
I have one!
Oh, I have him!
And then I place the orb to a ladder.
Then I use the... hold the use button.
Oh gosh, this is, I feel like, gonna be a bit of a mess.
Okay.
And then we hold the use button to grab the ladder and pull yourself up.
Hold the use button.
What's the use button?
Oh, the triggers!
The triggers.
Okay, okay.
Test run?
Yeah, this is... let's do a test run.
Especially because I want... I don't know how the camera will be.
I want to make sure that you guys are able to see and everything, so...
Wow!
I just noticed, like, the reflection in this thing is pretty good!
It looks real, right?
Wow.
It looks so good.
Alright, guys.
Test run.
Okay, hold on.
I'm stuck.
Guys?
I can't move.
Guys, I'm stuck.
Guys?
Guys, can you see?
You can't see my...
You guys, I'm stuck on the ladder!
You guys, help me.
You can just see my fingers.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
What a thrill.
Why are they all the way over there now?
With darkness and...
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
I'm gonna restart the world.
Respawn.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Gosh, that thing scared me again!
Okay, place... grab them.
Grabby grab.
And then...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
But don't actually open your hands, I think.
This is a... this is a...
One...
Two...
Three...
Let's see.
Place the orb to the ladder.
Use the hold button to grab...
Okay, I think I'm just gonna hold the hold button.
I think I'm just gonna hold it the whole time.
Okay.
Yeah, don't let the balls go.
Don't let the balls go.
Okay, here we go.
Um, I'm gonna also move you guys.
Like this.
A little bit.
Oh, uh, hold on.
You're gonna see my butt the whole way.
Maybe that'll do.
Are you guys two sideways?
There we go.
Oh.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Why am I so shaky?
Dang it, I messed it up.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
Why am I... Why am I shaking?
What's wrong?
Okay.
Yeah, I'm vibrating for some reason.
Um...
Why am I vibrating?
I got them.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm also gonna move chat over.
And I'm gonna move this over, the thing.
Okay.
I think now I'm properly ready.
I'm doing it!
When's the song start?
Oh!
With the darkness and silence through the night.
What a thrill.
I'm searching and I'm melting to you.
What a fear.
But you're so supreme.
Not for honor, but for you.
The music is quiet.
It's not me, though.
It's the world.
Oh, I can turn it up here.
There you go.
Holy!
It said it would restart automatically.
But it did not.
Restart!
I'm also gonna change the angle for you guys.
Hold on.
I'm gonna change the angle.
Maybe like that's better.
There you go.
Now you can see.
Reset.
Reset challenge.
Okay.
All right.
I know you guys can't see me super well.
But I think it's better if you guys see how far...
How much far...
Oh, no!
The restart button on your right to try again.
What's holding around, Snake?
Who's this?
The mission failed at the top!
Oh, I think it gives you a chance to restart if you want.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All right.
It gives you a chance to restart.
It's kind of nice.
All right.
Here we go, guys.
Okay.
Don't miss the...
Properly grab it.
All right.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's try again.
Oh, there it goes.
Oh, there it goes again.
There.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
There you go.
Yeah.
Okay.
How much further do we have?
Oh my gosh.
I gotta go faster.
This is actually such a workout.
I am still...
No, I'm not gonna make it!
I'm not gonna make it!
No!
I can't do the next part!
What's
rolling around Snake?
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Was the camera angle okay, or was the camera angle okay?
You would've made it.
I don't think I would've.
Yeah, that was good?
Okay.
My arms, though.
Oh my gosh.
Snake must be sprinting up that ladder, right?
Okay, Magic Doodoo Johnson.
I want to see you do this, huh?
And also gripping onto your controllers at the same time and making sure that you firmly grasp the next one.
Yeah, whatever.
I'll call you Magic Doodoo Stupid Comment Johnson.
That's what you are.
Okay.
Firmly grasp it.
That's what was my biggest concern was if I was going to grab it well enough.
Wait, the camera angle is not good at all, you guys.
You can't see my hand.
Hold on, let me try again.
You guys can't see me grasping it.
And by me, by grasping, I mean my ladder.
Maybe like that.
Nah, I descend.
What the hell?
If you imagine the perspective is horizontal, it's like a worm crawling on a railroad track.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see if this is better now.
Wait, you guys still can't see?
Hold on.
Sorry.
I want it to be good angle.
I want it to be a good angle for real.
Yeah.
I want you guys to see how much we got going on left.
I can't see my arm at all.
Where's the thrill?
I don't think we can have best of both worlds, everybody.
I think it's one or the other.
I think it's either you see my arms, which you can't even see here.
Or you see the top.
Okay.
Hmm.
Put the camera behind your butt.
When you put the camera on your chest, point it up.
Oh, that's a good idea.
Way better than Nano's idea.
Do I like that?
Oh my gosh, this is such a good idea.
Body cam, real.
Why is it green?
Oh, that's me.
That's my head.
Real GoPro footage, everybody.
Hello.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, no!
No!
This is why I was worried about going so fast.
So I just mean to say, this is kind of weird.
Sometimes you just can't see anything.
The camera runs out of battery, or the camera is out of AA battery.
It's not in criticize me.
Oh, fuck!
Ah!
No!
Oh my god!
I fell onto the ladder.
No!
You guys!
I never failed if you... can't get me!
Snake!
There's darkness through here.
Aw, man!
You're too short to make good progress.
This is... this is... this is... this is height disadvantage!
This is... I should have a height handicap.
Long strokes were a good idea, though.
Can we not call them long strokes?
Grab the sides of the ladder.
Can you do that?
They're really wide, though.
Oh, shit!
You can!
Wait, it's too difficult.
I think it's too difficult.
I'm going for it!
Maybe I should stand on a chair while I...
Ow!
No!
No, no, no, no!
Heart...
No, I can't sing the song or else I'll get distracted.
I have to concentrate.
I have to concentrate!
Oh my gosh.
I give my love a
round of applause No!
It's the way I fly to you
I'm still in a dream Please!
Please!
How do I...
How do I... How do I...
How do I go up?
Please!
How do I get up?
I'm stuck, you guys!
I'm stuck!
There it is.
Okay, hold on.
Give me a second.
I'll make you guys normal again.
My hands are shaking from gripping so hard.
Yeah, we did it, baby!
I'm basically Snake!
Yeah!
Ouch.
Oh, my fingers.
Oh, my fingers hurt.
You did it!
Thank you for climbing this really long ladder.
Be sure to check out the worlds through the door to your right.
For real adventure worlds.
Okay, what is this?
Kept you waiting, huh?
Oh!
I'm the box!
I...
I can't see anything.
Am I...
A multi-box drifting!
Hold on.
Let me save this.
So, I don't lose it, favorite it.
It's my...
It's my... It's my reward.
It's my reward for having, you know... It's my trophy.
It's my trophy.
I have to have it.
I'll give you the title of big box.
What else is here?
What's this?
Toggle mirror?
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
The sound effects scared me.
Well guys, this was a lot of fun.
I hope you guys had fun too.
Big box.
I can't even like grasp anything anymore.
Holy cow.
Oh, should I sing another song before I go?
One last song?
What song should I sing?
Doesn't have to be Metal Gear.
It can be anything.
One last song?
Snake Eater.
We just listened to Snake Eater like three times.
September?
Oh man, I think I have to.
I think I have to.
I think I have to sing September.
Oh golly.
You guys aren't sick of that song?
I don't think I would even know that song if it wasn't for GGStream.
Okay, give me a second.
Let me pop up the thing.
And let me also turn off the ambiance here.
Oh, let me type it.
Yeah, September's almost over so we gotta sing it before it's over, right?
Gotta sing it before it's over.
Do you remember?
Why does it keep getting small?
Da!
Do you remember?
The 21st night of September?
Love was changing the minds of pretenders.
No!
The window just may got small again.
Our hearts were ringing in the key that our souls were singing.
As we danced in the night, remember how the stars stole the night away.
Ya ni da, say that you remember.
Ba ni da, dancing in September.
Ba ni da, never was a clue.
La di da.
Ba di da, ba di da.
Ba di da, da di da.
Ba di da.
Hey, hey, hey!
My thoughts are with you.
Holding hands with your heart to see you.
Only blue talking love.
Remember.
How we knew.
Love was here to stay.
Now December.
Found the love we shared in September.
Only oh ba da ba da ba ba.
Sorry I'm having such technical difficulties today.
Today.
Hey, hey!
Ba di da.
Say that you remember.
Dancing in September.
Ba di da.
Never was a cloudy day.
And we said ba di da.
Start to remember.
Ba di da.
Dancing in September.
Golden dreams were shiny days.
Those bells were ringing.
Our souls were singing.
Do you remember?
Every cloudy day.
And we said ba di da.
Say that you remember.
Ba di da.
Dancing in September.
Never was a cloudy day.
Da di da.
Ba di da.
We doubt it all.
I was ready to go.
I was ready to go again.
Yeah!
Thank you guys!
Thank you for being our chat today.
I'll see you when I get back.
When I get back?
It's my birthday!
It's my birthday?
My birthday is the first.
The first, but we're celebrating on the second.
Sec...
Stop it.
The second?
And I have a big announcement.
Big, big, big announcement.
So please, come and watch.
And then, you know, you'll see what the announcement is.
Have fun at TGS.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, there you go.
Now I can say it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Wake me up when September ends.
And like, by the time I'm back, it's gone.
By the time I'm back, September's over.
So, you know what?
I will wake you up.
Wake you up in time for my birthday.
Bye-bye, everybody!
See you in like a week.
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.